away Hikaru what started as a slow paced
game turned into this complete mess
complete drama tell us the story of this
game yeah I mean the last one I you know
last time I was here and I played this
E4 line was the 2019 us championship
against sam7
um who I played here as well and
I mean it was kind of similar situation
in this game is that one where my
opponent got the double pawns Wesley
having these pawns on B6 and B5 and I
thought it was just a little bit better
in the middle game but it kind of well I
mean I think Wesley played very well
first of all that has to be said
um
but yeah keep going
uh foreign
no but I mean no so go back he didn't
play Bishop D4 at all got it ah okay
wait wait wait wait oh you're Diva yeah
it's like preparation for Fabiano or
something no no no no no this was your
game I mean all right you see the
sidelines so I thought I mean maybe
you're already doing more for fabians
um there we go yeah I mean it was a
position that I thought I was a little
bit better but it's very it's very hard
to judge I mean I have the easy move so
Wesley is the one who had to come up
with sort of the ideas
um in the middle game and then I just
started getting wildly out of control
like I I mean there were a couple of
options first of all I didn't play Queen
G4 but if you but but let's just keep
going with the game because there's you
know so many interesting moments um
yeah now he played he didn't go Queen G4
again he played uh coffee eight okay
we're having some problems because this
should be updated though it doesn't
matter I mean I I remember the whole
game so but the thing is like see so
when he played rookie I thought he might
play B5 and I spent some time looking or
when was I was thinking I was thinking
about B5 and then he played rookie eight
F four and then B5 and I thought this
order was imprecise but somehow Wow
Computer just doesn't give much I mean
it felt very good for me like it feels
like I'm trying to do my best Bobby
Fischer impersonation with a good Bishop
versus a bad Knight
um I thought everything I did was
logical I thought C5 was correct it was
the best move and he was defending I
mean I I somehow yeah I played rookie
one which I thought was also the best
move then he played C6 and yeah and here
also I have a tough decision do I take
on D6 or do I play F5 it means it's very
hard to judge so after F5 Queen two
let's just say E7 I don't know what's
going on I mean I can take on D6 and
play something like G4 but at the end of
the day
I figure if I'm not getting D4 in the
center here and I'm just pushing pushing
the p on the king side with G4 G5 then
like it's hard to believe this is a real
Attack I mean it looks I mean either
it's great or it's really stupid one way
or the other and I just thought it
didn't make a whole lot of sense from a
general standpoint like why do I want to
go for this
um so I tried to keep it under control
and I thought everything I did was good
wow zero is crazy so I go Queen F2 and
then once they played F6 which I thought
was a good move and yeah it was real
pity because when I spent all my time in
this position to play D4 he takes F4 I
was gonna go Queen takes off four Queen
takes E4 takes takes D5 but I completely
missed Rook A6 here completely missed
this move um because if black plays Rook
C8 instead then I have rook fe1 and I
mean maybe it's still a draw anyway but
the Rook is getting in yeah but if you
put the Rook on A6 he has to find
through the AIDS yeah but I mean no but
the point is on Rook A6 go back to D5 or
k6 yeah yeah the problem is on Rook A6
now when I go rookie one you I mean you
can just take on D5 stars but you can
even just trade the Rooks just just to
or no you can't sorry no you have to
take on D5 first
season yeah D6 is hanging at the end so
it doesn't work so then I have to go for
this whole yeah this whole crazy line
but it's very principled of course with
E5 very forcing
um yeah
of course now I open up the bishop
rookie one Queen D5 and I play Queen E2
here I mean
I mean in retrospect considering there
was no second time control probably if I
could do it again I would have played
like Bishop E5 or Rook D1 and just made
a draw but
um I I kind of I I felt like going for
it so I played Queen E2 and I think yeah
but after I just take I thought this is
actually the same thing oh Knight G6
all right G6 yeah I mean because yeah
this is why it's still equal no I know
but this is why compute this is why
computers are so good because I didn't
even consider this I only saw an ic4
Knight D3 to get back to the center I
didn't see this Knight G6 line but yeah
yeah it's still I mean it's it's wild
because he goes to Knight C4 and I I
just assumed that after takes takes King
F7 there has to be some kind of puzzle
here some kind of big study with rookie
seven but I mean it still says zeros
which is insane because after King G6
takes I mean originally I wanted to go
Bishop C3 after King H6 no no Rook two
seven keep going up King H6 I want to go
Bishop C3 Bishop C3 yeah
but then there's Knight to E3 and if I
play Rook C1 I think there's Knight two
D1 that's the problem there's Knight D1
and now now the Knight is jumping and
yeah yeah I mean I saw this
um you know another one that I also
consider was Bishop F6
Queen takes D6 and G4 but I think after
just Knight E3 I don't I don't have a
Checkmate like it looks really good but
there's no Checkmate yeah yeah ah I've
Rook G8 though
oh I have this one
ah this is just a drawer yeah I mean
probably okay no but I mean it's still
this is another beautiful mating concept
with the pawn on G4 to go Rook G8 Bishop
G5 because the only mating construction
I saw was with H4 Rook G5 I didn't I
didn't see this one with G4 Bishop G5
this is actually beautiful yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I mean I I didn't so yeah
so I I use a lot of time Play Bishop A1
I should just play this instantly rather
than burning like 15 minutes
um yeah Wesley played Knight E3
which is a blunder or something yes or
ah so H4 actually is winning what well
sort of knight uh H4 I think Queen D3
was played Yeah so basically I played as
quicker maybe I would have found it but
the thing is like here I was down to
like seven minutes yeah it goes Queen D
wait wait a second what king H3 is the
best no wait no no wait a second wait
wait a second why is King of Sugar Queen
takes D6
I mean I was gonna play King H original
but there's Queen takes D6
95 oh I have Bishop f8 no wait what
yeah
no no actually I saw no no I actually
saw this but I was I saw this with the
other order with Rook F5 I did very
briefly see his takes five but then King
G6 Bishop B5 Queen E6 yeah I very
briefly saw this but this one I'm losing
yeah no more oh yeah yeah I mean if I
have 20 minutes me maybe I can find this
but still it is very very easy yeah yeah
I think for half a second yeah I did I
did see this but I only saw I work F5 I
didn't see the other order with Bishop
E5 first but I mean all right like I'm
not stockfish so like this is really
asking asking for a lot but he did play
King 12 too that's fine yeah but this
was also based on a complete um
misunderstand yeah I did see Rook F7
which draws but I mean at this point I
when I went King F2 because I saw I mean
if I saw King issue Queen G6 request of
Knight D5 and G3 takes Rook F6 which
should be a draw so when I when I went
for this at this point after
sorry you took on A1 yes
already at this point when I won King F2
I thought okay I'm going for it no
matter what I'm I'm gonna try to win but
of course without a second time control
and only like a couple of minutes it's
impossible this two is drawing wow yeah
throw G5 is no but I I thought I mean I
thought I just blundered this because
after a night he played 95 yeah D7 Queen
h8 yeah
yeah now I played yeah I played rookie
four which is I mean this was just a
huge blunder because I missed um
because we both thought that Wesley was
okay we both thought thought that I mean
Wes and I both thought that he was
winning yeah because basically after
queenouts of King G1 like I spent like
all my time calculating worksheet five
and it was to get to this line and I
thought Queen E6 I have rookie six and I
just you know I just won the game but
there's plenty one Queen yeah so like
when I spent my five minutes I was
looking at like Queen h8 with Knight C7
and all kinds of craziness and I think I
thought I was probably winning there but
um yeah so I make the queen and this
this is still a draw and you were
shaking your head at this point during
the game
Wesley just popped he said he said win
the engine during the game awesome if I
go to F2 it's a draw yeah somewhere
around here I already like I thought I
just thrown the game but
uh so if I go to F2 G3 it's still so
that's why you were shaking your head
you thought you were lost at this point
yeah I mean I I because because the
whole thing was I thought I had this
rookie 68 Queen I win the game so when
there's Queen Essence Queen D6 it's
already feels very bad but King Asia
yeah and Wesley gone Queen C7 did you
spot yeah I thought after Queen C7 maybe
I have some some weird attempt with like
King H3 oh but there's there's Queen D7
yeah that's the problem because I think
I thought King H3 Queen F7 rookie five
was still maybe some chances because now
I have some G4 or something yeah I guess
Queen D7 wins anyway but it feels like
there might be some attack here yeah
yeah and then fortunately I mean Wesley
didn't do this he played the uh the
obvious move which is Queen D4 he's a
very practical move right Queen to D4
yeah queen of Faith apparently was
winning as well but yeah but it's hard
to go into zen game with Queen office
yeah and then after fortunately I
spotted King G3 and now I think it's
it's still a draw so yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's very very very very strange
game I mean I I guess we both actually
played pretty well I mean I I don't
think I mean it's hard for me to really
be disappointed because there's there is
that one win with King issue but I mean
that's really I mean I I just didn't see
the the move order sequence because I
did see Rook F5 Rook F5 there should be
five Queen E6 with that one I think I'm
losing so that's what it is crazy game
today tomorrow with the black pieces uh
what do you expect from Wesley yeah I
mean it's I I don't know I think at this
point I've done what I came here to do
which is not lose rating points so you
know just just play and see what happens
but I think on the bright side at least
people should should have enjoyed this
game today oh yeah it was a great game
Hikaru congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thank you
uh great game just absolutely great game
mesmerizing